Love is blind is the craziest show on Netflix
and this is coming from a guy
who's watched every episode of The Island
Oh my God! I didn't KILL anyone!
This is a show that just NEEDS to be seen
to be believed
And yes. The puns do get worse as the video goes along
In this video we're going to take a deep dive
into romance and answer the question everyone's been asking
Is love blind?
OoOoh! We're going to get into that piece of work
And who better to explain the show than Nick Lachey
and his wife, Vanessa
Because if there is anyone who knows anything about love
it's this guy
There's a donkey show. Do you want to?
What is that?
A girl has sex with a Donkey
To see if love is actually blind
contestants spend the next week
engaging in dates in these rooms called "pods"
without actually seeing their partner
Only if and when a proposal is accepted
will the couples be able to see each other,
move in,  and get married
Will you marry me?
yes
The experiment gets off to a great start
with contestants immediately making connections
and who could forget most of these contestants
we literally only see once and never again
The first episode is filled with people we only see once
and then they just kind of dissapear so ...
Tin foil hat theory, I honestly think some of these contestants are plants
Like take for example: Rory over here
Remember this guy?
We never see him talking to any of the girls
He only gives emotional pep-talks to the other guys
Deep breath in
Scary, right! Something that's powerful
Force the air out
I also like how everyone in this show is given the most generic job titles
Lexie: Sales Manger
Jessica: Regional Manager
Damian: General Manger
and Cameron: Scientist
Within the first few days, couples form with Cameron and Lauren being the first to say their I love yous
Keep in mind this happens 30 minutes into the first episode
And pretty soon the proposals begin to fly
I want to ask you. Would you marry me?
Hello?
For those of you who don't know, this is Mark and Jessica
Who agree to an engagement, even though they are 10 years apart
Which for Jessica isn't a big deal at all, right?
He is the most special person I've ever met and age is not a factor for us
RIGHT?
Me and Mark are soooo dissimilar
Yeah! I mean we're 10 years apart
I will ... I'm going to be open and honest with you
okay
You're 10 years younger than I am
When you're a 24 year-old woman and you're a 34 year-old woman, that's two different things
Jessica is a piece of work
Not only does she feed her dog wine
Yes. That actually happened
But she gets upset at one of the dudes for not knowing what he wants
And then proceeds to take Mark
A guys she doesn't like at all, all the way to the altar only to dump him
This girl literally has a break down while putting on her wedding dress
I still need time. I'm sufficating
She's such a mess that just a day later, after questioning her relationship with Mark
she say's stuff like this:
Feels like, he completes my life. You know?
Aww
Now I have to bring up that based on the way that the show depicted her
it seems she really has a drinking problem
It's a big of a red flag
With the exception of a few scenes, she's almost always holding a giant glass of wine
And unlike shows like the Bacheleror where women is rare to see the women get blackout, sloppy drunk
Love is Blind does not shy away
I could be getting married and I love him and I'm so lucky
You and your dude
And I know you
I KNOW you baby
I KNOW YOU
If you were ever to actively go after my husband
The drinking is so our of control in this show
that in multiple dates the contestnats have to drink out of these aluminum cups
because they've been smashing too many glasses
By episode 3, 6 couples have merged for the next phase
Cameron and Lauren
Gina and Damien
Amber and Barnet
Kelly and Kenny
Mark and Jessica
and Carlton and Diamond
The next phase of the show I call the "Honeymoon" phase
even though the're not married yet
Which sees if the couples can translate their emotional love into the physical
And Nick and Vanessa arrives once again to collect their paychecks
Seriously. Their screen time the entire season is shorter than Nick's marriage with Jessica Sympsons
That was a little uncalled for
While in Mexico, the couples really get to find more out about each other
and the pair that really struggle with this are Carlton and Diamond
Meet Carlton! No, not that one
who is the son of a preacher
You make daddy feel good
Oh! We walking down the isle
I'ma get you a boggo stick so you can hop out of your feelings first
whatever
Carlton has failed to tell Diamond something you should probably tell your fiance
He is also into men
And while things don't end well for Carlton and Diamond
Damien isn't quite interpreting Gianina's signals
I won't live at your pace
The sex is not ... important
It's looking pretty romantic in there
I'm just telling you it's been 435 days
I went to the beach so I could remember how it feels to have my ass smacked
But I'm just not hungry right now
What about dessert?
Oh, for the love of God Damien!
I am desert
Ugh!
I got a boner
Meanwhile, Jessica struggles to come to term the boy she fell in love with
is attached to someone she is clearly not psychically attracted to
Which is pretty funny since her voice does this weird baby thing
I love hearing the waves crash on the beach
That's like my favorite thing in the whole world
Where have I heard this before?
I love lsagna. I love cheese
And while paradise may be working out for some
Is it inappropriate to put in a prenup that you want sex everyday?
Things come to a head in the final confrontation between Carlton and Diamond
I love you
I love you too
Oh oh! Sorry! Wrong clip
This is why I don't deal with b*tches like you
Oh! I'm a b*tch now?
F*ck you!
F*cker! Watch my a** to the next d*ck, boy!
Watch your wig! Cause it keeps sliding!
I just can't believe it didn't work out between those two
I also want to take a moment to highlight a few things that I just found unromantic about this show
Like how some of the outdoor dates are so poorly lit, it looks like I'm watching a home video
Or the fake actors they sometimes have meeting in the background
Oh wait! They don't even have meals
And as the honeymoon phase of the show reaches it's end
Things are still rocky for Mark and Jessica
I'm being patient, but everyone else is having sex
and it sucks
Guess old "blue balls" here is getting frustrated that Jessica isn't putting out
But he'll complain her when she's constantly taking sh*t behind his back
The way I feel when I'm around Mark is not the way I want to feel around to my fiance
When he kisses me, it doesn't feel ... right
uncomfortable
Not to mention she often takes off her ring
And that's because she is still super attracted to Barnet
Who she made a connection with in the pods
I'm physically attracted to Barnet
Just to put things into perspective how Jessica just does not care about this relationship
She shows up to her romantic date in a grey-T and her hair in a bun
Like this is what you'd wear when you're home alone watching a romantic-comedy with a tub of Ben & Jerry's
Oh! I needed that
With some relationship blooming and other a flaming train-wreck
The couples move on to the next phase of the show
Where they have to live together in the real world
And with 20 days until the wedding
Things start to get even more serious
Barnet finds out Amber is in terrible debt
And Giania is pissed at Damien's listening skills
I am good at listening
Motherf*ker
Listen!
For TWO seconds!
I'm listening to you since the day we ...
Hold on! Is that Jessica just chilling in the back eating chicken?
And she is an absolute mess
Just look at her! Like a rag doll
And if things could't get worse for Mark
After the party ends, Jessica says this to him:
I think Barnet is f*cking sexy and like hot and like
Even the dog isn't having any of it
The next episode deals with the couples meeting the familes
Which is just filed with some absolute gems like Jessica trying to give wine to Mark's underage nephew
John, you ready?
Not yet? Not quite?
Or Giannina not being satisfied in bed
You know how you tell me this is the best sex of your life
Have you noticed that I don't return the compliment
You didn't have to say that
I also notice this weird thing
and I'm not sure if the producers did this
that a lot of the times when the couples talk
they're talking in separate rooms
Not able to see each other
Almost as if they're trying to recreate that scenario they had in the pods
One of the more interesting meetings is that between Cameron and Lauren's parents
since Cameron is a bit anxious how they'll feel about her daughter marrying a white boy
And what better way to relate to your future African-American mother-in-law then by rapping
Blast-off. The course is a like a crash collision
'cause every choice we make is like a rash decision
But the truth is
Yeap.That just happened
With only 8 days before the wedding, tensions mount
Like Giannia gets pissed at little things
like Damian checking his phone
While later that night she does the exact same thing when Damian is in the middle of a heartfelt conversation
Yeah. And, since we've gotten back
Wait, seriously?
Oh! And we have to talk about the bachelor and bachelorette parties
First of all, the girls get a stripper, a Drag Queen show, and a venue with enough disco balls to induce everyone to seizures
What do the guys get? An art gallery
Needles to say it's an absolute sh*t show
With Jessica in top form
Look at me and know me
But the second last episode leaves with a big cliffhanger
Our first wedding
Now I gotta to say, this is absolutely bat sh*t insane
Each of the couples have to decide whether or not to go through with marriage in front of their families
Leaving those who get dumped humiliated in front of their friends and family
And just look at Damian when he is asked if he wants to marry Giannia
It's like he is taking a big dump
Which is exactly what he does, choosing to not go ahead with marriage
And if things couldn't get any worse for Giannia
Damian proceeds to tell her entire family why things didn't work while she runs away and falls on her *ss
Look at me Damian
It's all for you
Giannia wants some answers, saying
Ah. Let's roll the tape
Motherf*cker. Listen!
Have you noticed that I don't return the compliment
Kelly also smashes Kenny's marriage hopes when she says she can't go through with it
And just check out Kelly's mom
She's like: ooh
I also don't know why Jessica and Mark get a way better wedding venue
Specially since, shocker, Jessica says she can't go through with it
And her post interview is really savage
I guess she's going to go back to drinking with her dog
This show does, however, have a happy ending for two couples
Amber and Barnet
And Lauren and Cameron
Both of whom, I believe, are still together
So did we learn anything through this 10 episode journey of love?
Is love really blind?
Well, I certainly am after watching this show
I'm kidding. I actually thought this was premium trash TV
And I hope this comes back for season 2
And they'll work out some of the kink and hopefully tighten the pacing of some of the episodes
'cause some of them were just way too long
Now I also want to give a shout out to an amazing channel that you HAVE to subscribe to
if you like dating shows or reality TV
This guy's theories and breakdowns are top-notch
So be sure to check him out. I left a link in the description
Also stay tune March 5 as the Love is Blind reunion will be dropping on Netflix
I'm not sure if I'll be doing a video on it, but we'll see
I hope you guys enjoyed the video
It's a little different then my normal ones, so let me know what you thought about it in the comments below
And make sure to give the video a like
You can also follow me on Twitter at @ThinkStoryYT
Until next time remember
Daddy loves you very much